*Seufzer*
*tragische Melodie*
*enttäuschter Seufzer*
Oh, ein Raffaello!
*dramatische Musik*
(in Zeitlupe) Warum?
Warum? Versteh ich nicht!
Das lag schon draußen aufm Boden, das ist voller Bakterien!
Ja toll, die sind jetzt auch leer!
Hmm... weißt du was?
Ich mach uns jetzt ein Raffaello das so groß ist wie diese Honigmelone hier!
Um es ganz genau zu nehmen ist mein XXL Raffaello sogar größer als die Honigmelone
und somit heiße ich euch herzlich willkommen zu meinem neuen XXL Video!
Und jetzt zeige ich euch, wie ihr das XXL Raffaello ganz einfach Zuhause nachmachen könnt.
Wir starten zuallererst mit der Creme. Dafür benötigen wir weiße Kuvertüre,
Schlagsahne und Mascarpone.
Die Sahne wird in unserem Topf einmal aufgekocht und sobald sie dann hochsteigt,
gießt ihr sie über die klein gehackte weiße Kuvertüre.
Das Ganze decken wir dann für etwa 5min ab,
damit die weiße Kuvertüre schonmal in der heißen Sahne schmelzen kann.
Anschließend verrühren wir das zu einer homogenen Masse.
Damit erhalten wir unsere Ganache, die jetzt etwas gelblich aussieht.
Das ändern wir aber später.
Zuallererst muss sie vollständig abkühlen.
Für den Kern des Raffaellos benötigen wir blanchierte Mandeln und weißen Zucker.
Da es selbstverständlich keine so große Mandel auf der Welt gibt,
müssen wir die Mandeln jetzt zuallererst anrösten und dann
mithilfe des Zuckers zu einem großen Kern verarbeiten.
Damit wir eine schöne runde Kugel erhalten, müssen wir die gerösteten Mandeln
jetzt grob hacken.
Den Zucker erhitze ich in derselben Pfanne auf mittlerer Stufe
bis er anfängt zu schmelzen.
Jetzt haben wir den perfekten "Kleber" für unsere Mandeln.
Die geb ich jetzt auch noch mit dazu und verrühr das gut miteinander.
Die Mandeln werden dann in den Händen zu einer Kugel geformt aber bitte, bitte
seid vorsichtig bei diesem Schritt! Ich hab mir Handschuhe angezogen
und meine Hände mit den Handschuhen in kaltes Wasser gelegt,
damit ich sie überhaupt anfassen konnte.
Lasst euch zur Not einfach helfen und schneidet die Kugel
anschließend in der Hälfte einmal durch.
Nach etwa 1 1/2 Stunden im Kühlschrank ist die weiße Ganache auch abgekühlt.
Es ist ganz wichtig, dass sie komplett kalt ist,
sonst lässt sie sich nicht aufschlagen.
Die fülle ich dann in meine Rührschüssel um, damit ich sie in meiner Küchenmaschine
mit dem Schneebesen aufschlagen kann.
Ihr könnt selbstverständlich auch euer Handrührgerät dafür benutzen.
Sobald ihr dann merkt, dass die Creme ziemlich hell geworden ist, gebt ihr
die Mascarpone mit dazu.
Achtet bitte darauf, dass ihr das nicht zu sehr schlagt,
ansonsten wird die Creme grisselig.
Das tut dem Geschmack zwar keinen Abbruch, aber das sieht nicht mehr so schön aus.
Nachdem die Mascarpone kurz eingerührt wurde,
ist die leckere Creme auch schon fertig und wir können starten,
unser Raffaello aufzubauen.
Für den Schritt benötigen wir außerdem noch geschmolzene Kuvertüre
und Waffelblätter. Die bekommt ihr in jedem größeren Supermarkt.
Ihr habt jetzt 2 Möglichkeiten: Entweder ihr nehmt euch eine beliebige Schüssel,
die hat wirklich jeder zuhause und kleidet sie mit Alufolie ein.
Dieser Schritt ist auch ganz wichtig, damit ihr die Halbkugeln später
auch wieder aus der Form bekommt.
Ich hab von meinem Toffifee Video noch die Silikon Halbform da,
deswegen verwende ich die auch in diesem Video.
Das XXL Toffifee Video verlinke ich euch selbstverständlich am Ende dieses Videos.
Unsere Waffelblätter tunken wir in etwas Milch für eine Sekunde und lassen sie dann
etwa 1 1/2 Minuten stehen, damit sie schön weich werden
und sich unserer Halbkugel Form anpassen.
Dann kann's auch schon losgehen.
Wir streichen etwas von unserer weißen Kuvertüre in die Form
und geben dort die Waffel drauf.
Und geizt auch nicht mit der Kuvertüre, denn je mehr ihr verwendet,
desto stabiler wird eure Kugel später.
Sobald dieser Schritt getan ist, geben wir unsere Creme hinein.
Nun kommt unser Mandelkern ins Spiel.
Wir hatten den ja anfangs in der Hälfte durchgeschnitten
und jetzt geben wir eine Hälfte mit der Schnittseite nach oben in die Mitte.
Ganz wichtig dass die Halbkugel für mindestens 4h ins Gefrierfach wandert,
damit sie auch schön fest werden kann.
Selbstverständlich benötigt ihr 2 dieser Halbkugeln,
die hab ich in der Zwischenzeit auch schon hergestellt
und entferne sie jetzt aus der Form.
Die abstehenden Waffeln schneidet ihr dann ganz einfach
mit eurer Küchenschere ab, damit die Kugeln auch besser aufeinander passen.
Als Kleber dient jetzt unsere geschmolzene weiße Kuvertüre.
Die geb ich auf den Rand der Waffeln und geben dann die zweite Halbkugel mittig darauf.
Sobald die 2 Halbkugeln dann mittig aufeinander liegen,
könnt ihr mit eurer Winkelpalette noch einmal alles schön glattstreichen am Rand.
Da unser Raffaello tiefgefroren ist, ist die Kugel kalt und die warme Kuvertüre
wird dementsprechend schnell fest.
Also arbeitet hier bitte schnell, gebt etwas weiße Kuvertüre auf die Kugel
und bestreut sie dann mit reichlich Kokosflocken.
Nach diesem Schritt ist unser XXL Raffaello auch schon fertig
und bereit zum großen Wiegen.
Und jetzt wird mir auch gerade klar, warum ein Raffaello einfach nie reicht!
Das sind nur 10g!
Und jetzt kommt unser XXL Raffaello.
Mehr als 3kg bringt es auf die Waage
und somit vollkommen ausreichend für mich!
Das Riesenraffaello steht dem Original in nichts nach,
denn geschmacklich war das total lecker!
Und wir haben es wirklich sehr genossen.
Falls ihr das Ganze jetzt nachmachen möchtet,
dann schaut doch mal in die Infobox.
Da habe ich alle Mengenangaben für euch aufgeschrieben.
Und ich freu mich auch, wenn ihr bei meinem nächsten Video wieder einschaltet.
Tschüss!